speaking of rings you have a cat named
frank ocean did you see frank ocean's
luxurious [ __ ] ring that he released
that's amazing
i love uh black progress did you see it
at his progression did you see this
thing it's twenty five thousand dollars
i didn't see it but i mean i didn't see
i didn't i mean i don't know
it looks like a very nice men's
engagement ring my dog zack fox posted
it on his page and said he needs help
he's hilarious he's crazy he's so funny
yeah yeah yeah i know i know what you
talking about yeah we love frank though
we need frank to drop music yeah yeah
he's another one of them he's you know
what i'm saying like you said that's
what you were talking about earlier not
a commodity not here to be your
commodity bro 100 he's just going to do
what he wants when he wants to do it
when it feels good and it feels good
the [ __ ] ring is outside that [ __ ] is
amazing
my name is in 2050 right now he said 20
can you imagine if you're the guy that
spends 25 thousand dollars on that like
imagine how rich you got to be to be
like it costs 25 000. 25 000 dollars
no don't get one that's weird why not a
[ __ ] ring
i feel like it's a weird lady you just
throwing on with it right quick
i don't know i don't know i'm not sure
i'm not sure uh it's being marketed for
the uh you know for the uh guys
right here yeah let's stop stop yeah